all right
i have another caption contest results
video here
for you so this is the image
this was taken during a packers game
here at our place
and you see me in my shirt and then i've
got some
snacks you know some ham and cheese and
pickles and olives
there and that is sassy the cat
who jumped up on my lap and then jumped
up on the chair
and she is sniffing at a piece of cheese
but she also you know absconded with a
bit of ham
during that time so i put this out there
and we got a lot of good
captions for it i picked the top ten
before we get into the top ten there are
some
let's call them honorable mentions that
have to do with some puns
there were several that basically made
the same pun
doc to his wife no honey i said
charcuterie not
chatkutari shot is of course you know
french for cat
and then there's shar cattery and
shark cattery board deluxe now
the the top 10 included a few puns and
here's one of them
one must imagine sassy puss happy right
so this
is from a reference to albert camus
famous line in the myth of sisyphus i
think one
one of those lines that a lot of people
have never read the book know
and they use that we must imagine
sisyphus happy so we must imagine
sassy puss happy there's another good
pun right here this is a nietzsche
reference the world is the will
to meower and nothing besides of course
a reference to
nietzsche claiming that the world is the
will to power
and so that's pretty good and then we
get into some other
quips that i thought were good this is a
really good one greg
i wasn't finished with cat you're
finished with that meaning that she's
gonna take it no matter what
and here's a somewhat longer one
to be read in a steve irwin voice so i'm
going to try to do
my my best here in the central part of
wisconsin we see the remnants of what
used to be the prestigious
egyptian cat it's not very good at all
what used to be a symbol of royalty and
godhood is now succumb to feasting on
the everyday treats of the common man
just look at that fierce gaze as it
stares down the pickle on the right
not bad right and then here's here's
some hegel ones now this is coming from
hegel's phenomenology of spirit
even the animals are not shut out from
this wisdom but on the contrary show
themselves to be most profoundly
initiated into it
for they do not stand idly in front of
sensuous things as if these possessed
intrinsic being but despairing of their
reality
completely assured of their nothingness
they fall too without ceremony
and eat them up and they're sassy doing
precisely that eating my
my ham turning it into nothingness then
we have another
shorter one in a brash display of
self-consciousness
gregory quietly observes as the feline
flips
the master slave dialectic on its head
actually
it wouldn't be flipping the master slave
dialectic
in part because the slave provides the
master with the things
that they consume and the master doesn't
really do much of anything other than
you know remain the master and we
provide sassy
with all sorts of nice things and she
doesn't you know
other than like being a cat and being
comfy and purring and all you know being
cute she doesn't really do anything
for it so uh but you could say it is
flipping the master slave dialectic and
that we treat our our pets as
akin to servants or you know something
like that
now here's a switch uh referring to
schrodinger's cat if you don't know
about that experiment you know
there's the chance that the cat is alive
there's also the chance the cat is dead
there's a you know
has to do with a radioactive isotope and
you don't know until you open the box
so this is playing off of that here we
have a scientist observing schroding
schrodinger's
noms tasty things do the cat snacks
exist
or don't they but we actually see that
they exist because they're
right in front of us at the time
here's another one that references the
care of the self
sassy defines the care of the self as
the intentional and voluntary actions by
which
she sets rules of conduct to transform
herself
and change her singular being by eating
all your
hors d'oeuvres so this is referencing
foucault's notion of
care of the self and you know cats
do they transform themselves do they
develop virtues do they
think about how can i become a better
cat and move towards my
cat nature probably not so much but she
will in fact eat the hors d'oeuvres
at least the cheese and the ham here's
another one
greg may be a student of stoicism but
clearly he is no match for sassy the cat
who has mastered the wisdom of
epicurus epicurus was of course well
known for enjoying
cheese in his garden
you know being a student of stoicism i
don't think
keeps you from being robbed of your your
food necessarily or
you know but it could help you be
willing to share your food
especially with a beloved cat like that
and
finally we have one that's referencing
what's going on here in wisconsin cat
sure hope the packers make it to the
super bowl
i bet the pickings will be top notch and
that's probably
true as i say this right now we are
just before the championship game for
the
national football conference and if we
win that that is the packers win that we
go on to the super bowl
and then we might have some uh some
better snacks
that sassy would really enjoy
um she doesn't care about the football
at all but you know we do
so yeah there you go those are the
10 best captions on this caption contest
i'll do more of these
in the future so you can stay tuned and
thanks for submitting them everybody and
that's pretty much it
you